über ein halbes jahr sind die taliban an
der macht ein halbes jahr herrscht angst
und die not wird immer größer
[Musik]
da ist die frauenrechtsaktivistin die
jeden tag ihr leben riskiert
da ist der familienvater der aus geldnot
seine niere verkauft hat
da ist der taliban der in den straßen
kabuls patroulliert
und da ist der arzt vom roten kreuz der
trotz allem nicht daran denkt aufzugeben
wir erleben einen tag in einem
geschundenen land ein tag in afghanistan
es ist sieben uhr morgens in herat im
westen des landes die stadt erwacht in
der nacht fallen die temperaturen oft
unter null grad wir sind bei der familie
von rangun in einem kleinen dorf zehn
kilometer außerhalb sie leben in einem
einfachen lehmhaus einen job hat rangin
nicht das kleine mädchen ist zwei monate
alt das ersten reicht gerade so für brot
und tee
wir haben nichts zu essen meine kinder
sind hungrig und traurig meine frau ist
krank ich schwöre zu gott wir haben kein
essen mehr
sie sind innerhalb afghanistans geflohen
vor den jahrelangen kämpfen doch die
situation werde immer schlimmer sagen
sie uns aus verzweiflung hat der
familienvater vor vier monaten seinen
ihre verkauft die narbe zeigt er uns für
die niere seiner frau hätten sie vor
einem jahr umgerechnet 2000 euro
bekommen doch jetzt ist das geld
aufgebraucht sie wissen nicht weiter
andere familien haben sogar ihre kinder
verkauft würden sie das auch tun
wenn die situation sich verschlimmert
und wir keinen ausweg mehr sehen denn
meine kinder krank werden dann müsste
ich sie verkaufen lieber verkaufen als
sie sterben zusehen wer will schon seine
kinder an krankheit oder hunger sterben
sehen
bereits vor der machtübernahme der
taliban war afghanistan eines der
ärmsten länder der welt der westen hat
seine hilfsprojekte gestoppt die usa die
geldreserven der regierung eingefroren
afghanistan erlebt die schlimmste
humanitäre krise seiner geschichte
800 kilometer weiter östlich beginnt
auch in kabul der tag für die taliban
einheit gibt es wärmenden tee danach
geht es raus in die kälte jan mohammad
ist kommandant der truppe schon als
16-jähriger hat er sich den taliban
angeschlossen
[Musik]
es war mein wunsch mein langsames freien
afghanistan weil wir alle kamen zusammen
und haben für unsere freiheit gekämpft
sie tragen jetzt die kleider ihrer
feinde uniformen der afghanischen armee
und amerikanische stiefel die sie
erbeutet haben genauso wie die high tech
ausrüstung der us streitkräfte
die taliban möchten uns ihre besten
krieger zeigen die einheit besteht aus
zehn männern sie haben nur das kämpfen
gelernt
jan mohammad hat die schule mit 13
verlassen wir sind auf dem weg zu einem
checkpoint vor dem innenministerium
der kommandant lässt uns alles drehen es
ist sehr ungewöhnlich dass die taliban
eine deutsche journalistin auf ihre
pickups lassen der job am checkpoint
seit monaten der gleiche autos
durchsuchen dokumente checken
verdächtiges melden jan mohammad war bei
der einnahme kabuls dabei er ist 31 und
hat seine familie seit sechs monaten
nicht gesehen
gehen ihre töchter zur schule
gehen zur schule
was wollen sie dass sie später machen
sie sollen ärzte nennen werde oder
ingenieurinnen
doch nach unserem 3 entscheiden die
taliban mädchen dürfen nur noch bis zur
sechsten klasse auf eine normale schule
gehen das gilt auch für die zwei töchter
von jan mohammad
im norden der stadt erleben wir was es
heißt sich als frau gegen die taliban zu
stellen die morgensonne kriegt auch hier
langsam über die bergrücken wir sind mit
der frauenrechtsaktivistin thema sammer
ja tali verabredet seit wochen kann sie
ihre wohnung nicht mehr verlassen die 26
jährige hält sich hier versteckt aus
angst vor den taliban
die taliban haben unsere fotos vor allem
von unseren protesten wir haben viele
videos online und sind ziemlich berühmt
sie wissen also genau wer wir sind
thema ist mitbegründerin eines netzwerks
das sich für die rechte afghanischer
frauen einsetzt sie waren die ersten die
nach der machtübernahme der taliban auf
die straße gegangen sind und für
gleichberechtigung demonstriert haben
über 400 frauen haben sich der bewegung
in ganz afghanistan angeschlossen immer
wieder organisieren sie proteste woche
zwischen gehen die taliban immer härter
gegen die frauen vor zuletzt hatten sie
einige aktivistinnen festgenommen
die haben keine infos über unsere
mitglieder wissen nicht wo sie sind und
wie es ihnen geht wohin die taliban sie
verschleppt haben sie wollen nicht
aufgeben wollen weiter protest aktionen
durchführen obwohl es jeden tag
gefährlicher wird
[Musik]
seit 50 jahren wird in afghanistan fast
dauerhaft gekämpft seit 50 jahren werden
menschen verwundet seit 32 jahren
kümmert er sich um die opfer alberto
kairo vom roten kreuz in kabul er hat
fünf regierungen erlebt auch die erste
taliban herrschaft vor über 20 jahren
doch er sagt so schlimm wie heute war es
noch nie
die situation ist grauenvoll sehr sehr
trostlos
viele menschen haben ihre arbeit ihr
zuhause einfach alles verloren für die
meisten ist es wahnsinnig schwer das
alles zu bewältigen also wenn man sagt
afghanistan ist ein armes land geworden
kann ich nur sagen
heute fast alberto kairo die prothese
des zehnjährigen tarik an vor
zweieinhalb jahren geriet er in den
kämpfen zwischen die fronten ein
schrapnell verletzte ihn schwer er
verlor beide beine er ist zum dritten
mal bei doktor alberto denn seine
prothesen müssen immer neu gemacht
werden
ausstrecken das sieht gut aus tut es weh
alberto kairo und sein team bauen
prothesen für jeden und sie behandeln
alle kinder erwachsene auch taliban der
kampa und des roten kreuz ist sein leben
er darf sich draussen nicht frei bewegen
das sind die sicherheitsvorschriften
trotzdem denkt er nicht daran zurück in
seine heimat italien zu gehen
ich bin überzeugt dass hier der ort ist
wo das rote kreuz sein sollte wir
arbeiten nun mal in kriegssituationen
und wenn wir gehen wer bleibt dann noch
ich fühle mich auch nicht als ziel von
bedrohungen
ich bin da selbstbewusst und ich habe
keinen moment daran gedacht das land zu
verlassen
zurück bei aktivist ins thema das dach
ist für sie die einzige möglichkeit die
sonne zu sehen und frische luft zu
schnappen es ist der glücklichste moment
des tages zimmer und ihre freundinnen
wollen eine kurze videobotschaft
aufnehmen die sie später über die
sozialen medien verbreiten sie wollen
dass die welt von ihrem kampf erfährt
und fordern dass die taliban nicht
anerkannt werden
es ist allen auf der welt klar dass sich
die taliban nicht verändert haben das
sind die gleichen wie vor 20 jahren sie
erlauben frauen nicht auf die straße
oder zur schule zu gehen
auf dem dach sind sie nicht sicher wenn
die nachbarn sehen dass sie hier
videobotschaften aufnehmen und mit einer
deutschen journalistin sprechen könnten
sie die taliban rufen
denn die sind überall auch die truppe
von jan mohammad patroulliert vor dem
mittagessen noch einmal durch die
straßen kabuls die stadt ist sicherer
geworden denn die das land früher mit
terror anschlägen überzogen haben sind
jetzt an der macht doch echter frieden
herrscht nicht der es verübt immer
wieder anschläge auf moscheen schulen
und krankenhäuser
wir sind auch hier um verbrechen zu
verhindern und sicher zu gehen dass sind
der stadt keine unruhen ausbrechen auch
dafür haben wir überall checkpoints
aufgebaut
es sind seltene einblicke die wir hier
in den taliban alltag erhalten jan
mohammad und seine einheit lassen uns
alles filmen es ist afghanische realität
in diesen tagen die taliban schwer
bewaffnet beim lunch in einem normalen
restaurant
wir sind zurück bei rangin er und seine
familie haben noch nie in einem
restaurant gegessen wenn er viel glück
hat kann er manchmal als tagelöhner ein
bisschen geld verdienen dann kaufte auf
dem basar der armen leute ein seit die
taliban und der macht sind erhält
afghanistan nur noch nothilfe durch
internationale organisationen
doch die reicht längst nicht
ein paar organisationen sind in unser
dorf gekommen aber sie haben uns nur in
listen eingetragen und registriert
geholfen haben sie uns nicht
seit dem krieg in der ukraine ist die
krise noch schlimmer der staat ist
zahlungsunfähig es gibt kaum noch
menschen die lohn erhalten die
weizenpreise könnten zur
hungerkatastrophe führen
feierabend bei den taliban in der
gemeinschaftsunterkunft machen sich die
männer die sich selbst als gotteskrieger
bezeichnen fertig für das gebet ihre
sehr strikte auslegung des islam haben
sie nie aufgegeben dass die
internationalen truppen nach 20 jahren
das land verlassen haben sehen sie als
zeichen gottes ihren sieg über die
ungläubigen
doch sind die neuen machthaber in der
lage das land auch zu regieren die
drängenden probleme zu lösen
natürlich haben wir in manchen teilen
des landes wirtschaftlichen problem das
bestreite ich nicht
aber so gott will werden
jan mohammad und seine männer sind eine
neue generation von taliban doch ihre
überzeugungen sind die gleichen wie
früher afghanistan als gottesstaat die
scharia als oberstes gesetz
gleichberechtigung menschenrechte
meinungsfreiheit haben keine gültigkeit
mehr
noch einmal treffen wir doktor alberto
kairo bei sich zu hause es ist ein
einfaches leben das er sich ausgesucht
hat in einem abgesicherten viertel in
kabul nur die italienische espresso
maschine erinnert an seine heimat die
fehlende perspektive in afghanistan nagt
auch an ihm
[Musik]
niemand weiß wie es weitergeht es wäre
einfacher wenn man sagen könnte es ist
jetzt für 12 monate schlimm und dann
wird es besser aber niemand weiß wie es
weitergeht das ist traurig aber jetzt
alberto kairo will weitermachen in dem
land das mittlerweile sein zuhause ist
den menschen in afghanistan jeden tag zu
helfen und so ihr leben zumindest ein
bisschen besser zu machen es ist für ihn
eine lebensaufgabe
zurück im dorf von rang ging
wir erregen aufmerksamkeit mehrere
männer zeigen uns dass sie ebenfalls
ihren ihre verkauft haben der
organhandel scheint hier besonders zu
florieren das zeigt wie weit die
menschen in ihrer verzweiflung bereit
sind zu gehen
ein tag in afghanistan unter den taliban
ein tag der nur ein ausschnitt der not
des elends und des leids in diesem land
ist